bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous ses
sens public votre rendez-vous deux
débats de reportages et des analyses sur
public sénat 90 minutes pour vous donner
des clés de compréhension des mutations
de notre société et des enjeux de cette
campagne présidentielle justement notre
débats d'actu il sera consacré au
désintérêt des français pour cette
élection pourtant majeurs de notre vème
république les propositions n'imprime
pas la faute aux candidats qui ces
souches au président qui se fait
attendre à la crise qu vide qui n'en
finit pas explications de nos experts
juste après ses titres
les électeurs ont la parole sur un thème
qui lui concerne de plus en plus de
français la précarité énergétique
reportage à compiègne avec un couple de
retraité qui vit dans une passoire
thermique à la limite de l'insalubrité
ray et puis comme chaque jeudi on vous
propose de décortiquer les propositions
sur un grand thème de campagne
c'est la rubrique demandez le programme
consacré ce soir aux retraites avec
cette question faut-il repousser l'âge
légal mais d'abord les français de moins
en moins passionné par cette élection
présidentielle jonathan du prix yeahs
c'est une campagne qui flotte qui
n'accroche pas les français plusieurs
enquêtes d'opinion dresse ce constat
déroutant selon un récent sondage ifop
52% des français déclarent s'intéresser
à l'élection présidentielle ces 26 % de
moins qu'à la même période en 2010 est
un désintérêt que les sondeurs explique
largement par l'omniprésence de la crise
sanitaire dans les esprits c'est clair
que le coc vide fiche des choses des
français vit avec depuis maintenant deux
ans cette crise inouïe inédite or nord
qui fait les français ont des
difficultés à se projeter campagne
présidentielle un moment privilégié où
les français regardent les candidats au
fond des yeux comme disait
où les français regardent les candidats
s'affrontent et là ce n'est absolument
pas le cas le coded shell le jeu
d'autres raisons plus politiques peuvent
expliquer ce manque d'implication des
français hormis l'ovni zemmour l'offre
électorale n'est pas radicalement
différente à celle de 2000 dix-sept
autres problèmes certains camps peinent
à se rendre audible la gauche notamment
éclaté entre sept candidats
effectivement la multitude de
candidatures peut pousser aussi une
incompréhension à une perte de sens mais
je pense que là on va rentrer dans le
vif du sujet c'est à dire que une fois
qu'ils avaient parrainage qui sont
passés ça sera un moyen de clarifier
aussi certaines candidatures le camp
pécresse et met une autre hypothèse si
les programmes des candidats n'imprime
pas c'est à cause d' emmanuel macron il
est le mieux placé dans les sondages
mais toujours pas officiellement dans la
course toutes les autres écuries
seraient donc quelque peu paralysés en
attendant qu'il se dévoile pour
l'instant le panda public très
volontairement est en retrait et en
parallèle l'ensemble de ses lieutenants
ces ministres sont plutôt dans une
démarche d' attaques de provocation
d'agressivité et je crois que c'est pas
une très belle image de la politique ce
qui nous intéresse avant tout nous c'est
débattre sur le fond sur des projets
voilà je crois que c'est essentiel que
on est enfin un accès sur le fond en
résulte une indécision des électeurs à
ce stade près d'un français sur deux ne
sait pas pour qui il va voter à deux
mois du premier tour tout est encore
possible
pour en débattre j'accueille batterie
gibelin bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes géographe géopolitologue directrice
de la revue hérodote françois michaud
bonsoir vous êtes le directeur général
adjoint d'opinionway vous publiez le
sacre de l'opinion c'est aux éditions du
cerf accueilli allemand françois-xavier
bourmaud bonsoir soffritti qu au figaro
vous publiez macron le pen le tango des
fossoyeurs c'est aux éditions de
l'archipel laetitia cru pense à chaque
mardi et chaque jeudi avec hot
éditorialiste politique bon soit la
campagne ces salles on appliquer le
titre à l'un de vos confrères c'est
brice teinturier directeur général
d'ipsos c'était sur france inter ipsos
france on écoute
position ça n'accroche pas c'est une
campagne tefal on a le sentiment que
tout glisse auprès des français qu'il
n'y a pas de d'éléments suffisamment
fort et structurant et dans les
personnalités non plus moi ça me fera
beaucoup quand vous regardez l'image des
candidats auprès des français elle est
relativement médiocre c'est une campagne
en tous les cas qui ne parvient pas à
qui ne parvient pas
maîtrisable pourquoi ça n'accroche pas
comme ça a été dit on est tous ils sont
tous un petit peu dans la tente de
macron celui sur lequel il voudrait
pouvoir
mener l'offensive qu'ils soient enfin
candidat c'est c'est sûr alors c'est
vrai qui a le code qu vide et que ça a
été une vraie préoccupation
et puis il ya fiq d'une certaine façon
le travail qu'a fait macron qui a été
quand même de faire exploser un peu un
débat qui était droite gauche bien
tranquille dans lequel on se
reconnaissait on choisissait son camp
sa famille tandis que c'est où la
famille pour les gens de gauche macro et
de droite et fait une politique de
droite et pour un certain nombre de gens
de droite macro effet une politique trop
à gauche bon donc déjà on est dans un
flou
là-dessus il n'y a aucun je vais dire
thèmes de campagne avec slogans forts on
attend ce que macron veut dire si on est
on est vraiment dans la tente de de ce
qu'il doit dire lui regarder sur sur
pécresse on a parlé d'elle quand elle a
réutilisé kaercher mai
et après on lui a dit non tu sais c'est
pas bien faut pas reprendre saab ont
donc de nouveau un peu calme plat
dans les annonces on a quoi on a offert
toute la ligne
vraiment on n'a pas grand chose sur
lequel se met pour toi ya des
propositions mais elle n'accroche pas la
gauche va convenir sans aller très très
vite on est avec une telle
diversité bon alors moi ce qui
m'intéresse et qui m'interrogent un peu
c'est comment la sensibilité des jeunes
à l'écologie non c'est pas des électeurs
pour jadot d'après reviendra cette année
je vais me libérer partager un peu la
parole béatrice sur qu'est ce que je
voudrais vous entendre françois michaud
est ce que vous faites le même constat
quand on quand on dit ça ne prit pas où
ça n'accroche pas campagne tefal oui
alors pourtant le niveau d'intérêt des
français pour l'élection présidentielle
a fortement progressé en janvier on sent
quand même qu'on a quitté la phase de la
précampagne et qu'on entre peut-être pas
dans la phase la plus active de la
campagne en tout cas que les français
commencent à s'intéresser davantage à
l'élection elle à suivre davantage je
crois que
cet élément cette difficulté pour les
candidats faire passer un message c'est
il ya évidemment une stratégie
d'attentisme on conserve ses meilleures
propositions pour le moment où le
président sera vraiment là
puisque pour l'instant c'est l'acteur
central qui manque encore dans la
campagne c'est lié aussi au fait que
sans doute il ya un manque de
renouvellement des des personnalités qui
se présente à l'élection un peu faire la
liste jean luc mélenchon déjà présent à
plusieurs reprises marine le pen
troisième candidature sont qui est qui
et sortants alors c'est moins le cas
c'est moins le cas à droite mais quand
même peut-être françois asselineau
peut-être nicolas dupont aignan bref
c'est pas une élection de renouvellement
et puis quand on regarde l'historique
des campagnes électorales les campagne
de réélection dans lesquelles un
président sortant est présent sont
toujours moins intéressante que les
campagnes de de plaine nouveautés comme
74 comme 2007 qui sont vraiment des
campagnes où il ya beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé de l'intérêt par exemple
j'ai ressorti un article de presse en
avril 81 le point
titré pourquoi la france by
80000 81 rétrospectivement on se dit ça
devait être une élection un formidable
l'affrontement entre françois mitterrand
et valéry giscard d'estaing les
observateurs de l'époque c'était match
retour est donc désormais y est c'est
drôle absolue françois mitterrand était
là depuis 1965 dans l'absolu oublie
aussi un c'est qu'il a mis du temps à
gagner à l'elysée donc
oui le moi j'ai une théorie c'est une
théorie de jeu reprend le une phrase de
mon ancien patron de tf1 patrick le lay
le temps de cerveau disponible c'est à
dire que le le monde je suis pas sûr
qu'on ait un temps de cerveau
exponentiellement disponibles et ce
temps de cerveau il est occupé par le
cos vide j'ai pas si vous ressentez ça
français mais même dans les
conversations qu'on peut avoir ou qu'on
peut entendre ça occupe toujours j'ai
pas les trois quarts des convertis leleu
la crise due cori dépôt de poser comme
une cloche sur la sur la campagne
présidentielle
le pays n'a pas encore la tête à ça et
puis un autre effet sur le sur le co
vide qui est maintenant depuis deux ans
que durant ces deux ans il ya eu deux
élections des élections municipales et
des élections régionales et qu'est ce
qu'on a vu avec des élections qui se
déroulaient sous qu'ovide plutôt une
tendance à reconduire les sortants or
emmanuel macron ça fait au delà du covin
cinq ans qu'il est donné gagnant au 2e
tour face à marine le pen tout le tous
les sondages sont assez réguliers là
dessus malgré quelques petits sacs ou et
donc il ya sans doute aussi pas de la
lassitude mais un désintérêt pour un
match qui a l'air d'être jouée joué
d'avancé et qui intéresse pas parce que
jamais
le maquereau malgré les crises malgré
tout ce qu'il a affrontés pendant les
cinq ans et mais il est toujours à 25%
au premier tour est donné largement
gagnant selon les adversaires qu'il
affronte largement gagnant au second
tour donc comme si le match était déjà
joué quel intérêt de le regarder ou de
s'y intéresser trop tôt et puis à côté
de ça il lui même joue de cette
situation il reviendra sans doute en
temporisant sur son cher son entrée en
piste laetitia effectivement on l'évoqué
le manque de renouvellement le monde de
nouvelles têtes vous pouvez si on fait
un peu de politique fiction a contrario
en fait j'étais plutôt en entrant un
plateau d'accord avec avec cela c'est à
dire qu'il manquait un de nouvelles ted
non renouvellement et non c'est pas vrai
parce que yannick jadot est relativement
neuf dans le paysage et puisqu'ils
portent aussi vous avez tout à fait
raison il peut incarner l'espoir de
cette jeunesse qui descendait tous les
vendredis dans les rues pour sauver la
planète il y à anne hidalgo qui n'est
pas neuve dans le paysage politique
français mais qui dans cette course en
tout cas à faire sa première complète et
puis et puis eric zemmour enfin c'est ce
candidat iconoclaste ce clown comme je
l'appelle depuis plus d'un an maintenant
et qui dans la voilà cette vague
populiste arrive en france et essaye de
faire et de réussir le même pari que
trump que et linski que d'autres avant
lui que beppe grillo en italie le
mouvement 5 étoiles en tout cas et donc
quand même il y a quand même de la
nouveauté dans cette campagne donc c'est
vrai que c'est assez étrange observé cet
attentisme et je pense qu'effectivement
la pandémie écrase beaucoup dans le mba
public il ya un autre élément ces
chiffres de participation aux primaires
si on compare les primaires si on
compare 2022 2017 c'est assez
vertigineux lr il ya eu 115 mille autant
il ya eu 4 millions
en 2017 à gauche moi la primaire
populaire 392 me tout le monde dédié ça
fait beaucoup mais c'était 2 millions la
primaire socialiste enfin bref on est on
est quand même dans il faut avoir ces
chiffres ces chiffres là en tête juste
une nuance sur les menus mer et l'air
c'était une primaire interne donc
concerner les adhérents le parti
socialiste n'y a pas eu de primaire
puisque anne hidalgo a été désignée la
primaire populaire c'est un espèce de
nid mal identifié un peu monté comme ça
à la dernière minute qui a sans doute
pas eu suffisamment de temps pour
mobiliser
sans arrêt sans doute été beaucoup plus
mobilisateur si toute la gauche
s'étaient mises d'accord pour participer
à cette primaire plutôt que d'être
désigné d'office pour certains candidats
sur l'aspect générationnel gibelin c'est
quand même une pierre dans le jardin de
yannick jadot ou parce que effectivement
on peut se dire et alors certes les
jeunes traditionnellement votre moins
intéressés par les élections notamment
le président ray mais quand même
pourquoi mais c'est comme mais quand
même comme vous dites c'est quand même
une interrogation il visiblement pour le
moment ils n'ont clanche pas et il ne
motive pas une une jeunesse qui comme
vous le disiez sortez tous les vendredis
là ça permettait d'aller au lycée non
plus donc il y avait un petit côté
saint-etienne pour le moment soit pour
emmanuel va courir pour marine le pen
mais exactement
et surtout le plus grand nombre ne vote
pas du tout du tout bon donc ça fait
quand même et aux jeunes entre 18 et 24
ans donc 6 millions de votants
potentiels
combien iront aux urnes
comment vous l'expliquez ça le décalage
entre une jeunesse qui s'engage pour des
valeurs notamment sur sur la défense de
la planète et qui pour autant soit va
pas voter soit se reconnaît pas dans le
candidat qui porte le plus la saisie d
il ya deux façons de il ya deux façons
de vous répondre d'abord
structurellement on sait très bien que
cette génération là de jeunes quelles
que soient les générations quelles que
soient les époques va - a voté parce
qu'il ya effet nos men jours ben voilà
il faut entrer de politisation et on
vote plus on est âgé plus on vote est le
signe le civisme est un réflexe qui
s'acquiert en vieillissant
et puis cette génération là en
particulier peut-être qu'elle est plus
intéressé par des formes nouvelles
d'engagements politiques qui sont pas
les formes d'expression traditionnels
que peuvent être le vote mais peut-être
la mobilisation sur internet peut-être
que ce genre d'action politique qu'on
évoquait à l'instant même le choix
d'orientation professionnelle le fait de
donner du sens à saka à sa vie
professionnelle en 60 l entreprise
plutôt qu'une autre quoi c'est une forme
d'engagement exactement ça peut être
aussi des engagements du quotidien dont
les actes de consommation par exemple
peut-être que tout ça ça les détourne
tout casser les éloigne des formes
d'engagement
traditionnels bon ça c'est vraiment le
défi et des délégués des candidats de
pouvoir les intéressés et les ramener
aux urnes alors un peu d'histoire les
déclarations les entrée officielle en
campagne dès des présidents sortants
1965 charles de gaulle on était trente
trois jours avant le premier tour
valérie giscard d'estaing 56 jours en 80
françois mitterrand en 81 8 ct 33 jours
jacques chirac 69 nicolas sarkozy 67 là
on est soixante six jours avant le le
premier tour emmanuel macron en est on a
toujours un point d'interrogation même
si les les rumeurs ont par la voix du
nord que ce n'était pas le moment qu'il
allait d'abord régler la crise j'ai
l'obsession de la phase que la phase
aiguë de l'épidémie le cri le pic de la
crise géopolitique actuel soit derrière
nous voilà ce qu'il a dit
il évite les micros tendus pendant son
déplacement il doit le jouer françois
guilbault est ce que doit le jouer faux
faussement tranquille à l'ats jacques
chirac
qui répondait à marie josé juan la ville
à observer ce qui se passait pendant la
précampagne de très près ce qu'il a vu
se dessiner c'est une campagne tout sauf
macron à partir du moment où vous avez
tous les candidats cantons où il a
absolument aucun intérêt à descendre
dans l'arène et à prendre des coups de
tous les côtés c'est quelque chose qu'on
a vu aussi dans le refus de débattre
avec tous les tous les candidats c'est
il ya absolument aucun intérêt et que
des coups à prendre donc il lui a plutôt
intérêt à temporiser il avait fixé dès
le départ une date qui était celle du 19
janvier le discours d'ouverture de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne à strasbourg ça ne pouvait
pas être avant voilà parce qu'il voulait
faire ce discours dans le dans le
costume de président de la république
pour donner du poids à son propos et
puis il a été il a été aidé et je n'aime
pas trop le terme et par le miel il ya
la crise qu vide qui lui permet d'avoir
une date fluctuante sur son entrée en
campagne en fonction de l'évolution de
la situation et des dates de levée des
restrictions et puis donc il a été aidé
par la crise ukrainienne qu'il a la
mécaniquement forcé à réendosser le
costume parce qu on ne débarque pas pour
négocier avec vladimir poutine dans la
peau d'un candidat
c'est c'est quelqu'un qui est
extrêmement dur en négociation façon
dans une crise aussi grave que celle là
on peut pas aller que ça l'aurait
affaibli dans le dans le cadre des
négociations mais évidemment vous vous
discutez avec vladimir poutine d'égal à
égal pas dans le costume de quelqu'un
qui est peut-être pas là qui sera
peut-être plus là dans deux mois donc il
ya aussi le mali il ya aussi le mali
c'est pas un candidat qui peut résoudre
la crise humaine il faut au moins que ce
soit le président de la république c'est
une affaire très compliquée extrêmement
difficile on peut pas dire m'emballer on
claque la porte et on rentre on ne va
pas pouvoir faire ça donc seul un
président de la république peut dans
cette situation extrêmement complexe
si je vous écoute de crise en crise
politique en crise ou de variants 29 mai
entrant regarder mitterrand a pris un
mois vous donnerons basse il faut il
élira un mois avant à vous pensez que
c'est si on est sur une situation qui
reste extrêmement tendue sur l'ukraine
enfin on en voit quand même des des
troupes en roumanie c'est pas loin on a
eu trois mille soldats américains qui
sont arrivés en pologne on a on est
quand même sur un moment vous savez une
personne ne veut faire la guerre pas
plus je crois poutine que des tas de
gens mais dans ce genre de situation il
peut y avoir un dérapage il peut il
toujours il y avoir un excès de zèle ou
quelque chose qui qui se passe mal donc
si la situation reste très tendue oui il
n'hésitera pas à attendre le dernier
moment ça moi j'en suis convaincu qu'il
a quand même fixer un cap à nouveau quai
paquet pas précis c'est le pic de la
crise géopolitique le tchèque de la
crise gigantesque on décide que c'est
une rencontre en tête à tête
éventuellement avec avec poutine est
passé de là les dernières négociations
les négociations de la dernière chance à
ce moment là le temps de laisser passer
un peu de temps il pourra mais en tout
cas ça lui permet de ne plus subir le
procès en président candidat enfin en
tout cas de le décaler un petit peu de
d'ailleurs il a décalé son déplacement à
marseille qui était prévu en début de
semaine prochaine pour peut-être
rencontrer vladimir poutine on a brûle
encore le calendrier l'agenda officiel
en mêlée poutine aussi peu laissé
passion combat est ce que oui mais pas
totalement bien décoré lui cadencé
horloge d'après vous avez le chancelier
allemand qui lui va aller voir poutine
donc on a tout un jeu comme ça un ace
malsaine et maquereau est ce que ça va
pas je crois d'ailleurs pas leur excuse
et moi seul ce qui va y aller ça c'est
reprend la main même si c'était
passionnant de d'ouvrir cette parenthèse
entre guillemets géopolitique et
internationale peut-être pour on l'a
déjà dit plusieurs fois sur ce plateau
mais ça m'intéresse à voir si ça évolue
le socle des macros est-ce qu'il est
toujours aussi solide aujourd'hui alors
c'est très frappant de voir que les
intentions de vote en faveur du
président sortant reste particulièrement
stable à hauteur de 24 25 % des
variations infimes y compris quand il ya
des événements qui est normalement
devrait affecter au moins temporairement
ses intentions de vote servir sa
popularité a un peu baissé mais passons
oui il son socle d'électeurs potentiels
aulas avant pour l'instant ça ne bouge
pas c'est peut-être aussi un signe
supplémentaire du fait que la campagne
n'a pas vraiment débuté en réalité le
président de la république a sans doute
intérêt à entrer en campagne le plus
tard possible et montrent est dans l'est
dans les intentions de vote ils
bénéficient et c'est le seul à avoir cet
avantage concurrentiel de sa position
vient de le rappeler quand vous êtes
chef de l'état vous êtes au dessus de la
mêlée on a bien vu dans l'histoire que
quand des chefs de de l'état passe de
président à candidats il ya une perte de
prestige quoi qu'il arrive vous ne vous
n'êtes pas un candidat comme les autres
mais vous êtes un candidat parmi
d'autres candidats
valéry giscard d'estaing disait je suis
un candidat président bon bah quand même
vous êtes aussi candidat et vous dira
gérard larcher disait candidat citoyens
on a en parlant d' emmanuel macron et
vous perdez quand même des attributs
spécifiques qui vous protège et qui vous
distingue positivement des autres
notamment cette stature internationale
dont on vient de parler alors il ya
aussi les tisser une dimension
médiatique dans dans notre analyse parce
que l'offre est pléthorique c'est une
tentative d'explication je propose cette
hypothèse que peut-être on peut se poser
la question de l'éclatement de l'offre
médiatique et ça donne un effet
kaléidoscope pour nous français au
finalement où que l'on regarde quoi
qu'on écoute si vous voulez que ce soit
à la radio la télévision notre téléphone
youtube un réseau social parce que
maintenant et politiques vous aussi avec
les influenceurs sur instagram on a
l'impression comme ça d'un kaléidoscope
avec des politiques partout qui répètent
le même message tout le temps et c'est
vrai que cette offre peut être
perturbante peut brouiller les pistes
surtout en l'absence du grand favori et
surtout cacher les enjeux vraiment de
l'élection alors du côté les politiques
que nous répondons on nous dit oui mais
aujourd'hui il faut être multi canaux
c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas
privilégier uniquement les médias
traditionnels il faut être partout
l'objectif c'est de toucher le plus
grand nombre c'est à dire des publics
qui ne sont pas captif de la télévision
je vais les trouver sur twitch par
exemple sur instagram très bien ça c'est
quantitatif l'objectif est peut-être
atteint mais de façon qualitative de
quelle façon touches sont les français
est ce que les français qui sont encore
au contact des politiques via un support
en tout cas le support qu'ils préfèrent
vont être davantage inciter à aller
voter c'est toute la question je n'ai
pas la réponse mais c'est le pari des
politiques là aujourd'hui avec aussi une
autre question c'est la question du rôle
des débat on va l'aborder vous l'avez
vous qui rapidement mais de débats
d'avant premier tour notamment il
pourrait jouer un rôle prépondérant les
débats c'est prépondérant sont des
marqueurs forts on le sait dans la prise
de décision des français alors à la
dernière élection présidentielle pour la
première fois il ya eu des débats avant
le premier tour mais la l'entourage des
manuels macron vous avez raison françois
xavier a dit déjà non il n'ira pas il
peut pas prendre de coups alors ensuite
par écho chez marine le pen a dit abbas
il n'y va pas moi je n'aimais pas et
puis valéo 6 alors si on a pas de débat
de premier tour qui sont quand même des
grands moments démocratiques pour la
décision des électeurs elle sera
vraiment imprévisible cette élection et
rappelez vous quand même des sondages
qui était absolument faillible pour les
dernières régionales donc ou
pourrons-nous peut-être nous raccrocher
pour essayer d'avoir un pronostic exact
avant le premier tour moi je vous dis
que tout est ouvert comme jamais un mot
sur la difficulté peut-être plus grande
pour vous de près de prévoir ou de
d'analyser les intentions de vote on
rappelle qui a encore beaucoup de
français ne savent pas du tout ainsi
vont aller voter 2 pour qui oui elle en
est encore là oui absolument c'est une
difficulté qui existe dans toutes les
élections même si l'élection
présidentielle de ce point de vue là est
la plus simple est une circonscription
nationale il ya un débat qui même s'il
démarre pas vraiment quand même beaucoup
plus intense que le débat qu'on peut
avoir dans des élections locales donc
même s'il ya des difficultés il ya des
candidats nouveau il ya plusieurs
candidats qui sont assez proches donc il
faut
arriver à pouvoir les départager mais
nous espérons que le rapport de force
évoluent et de ce point de vue là vous
avez raison les débats c'est vraiment ce
qui transforme le rapport de force pour
qu'on puisse savoir sortir de
l'indécision dans lesquelles nous sommes
actuellement alors est-ce qu emmanuel
macron doit y aller on va d'abord écouté
la réponse du président du sénat gérard
larcher c'était ce matin sur rtl il met
la pression sur le prix dans la
rythmique encore faut-il que nous ayons
un sparring partner hier est ce que le
candidat non candidat président de la
république qui se fait représenter
devant un syndicat de police par son
ministre de l'intérieur
nous avons la nécessité d'un débat
démocratique
donc le président de la république qui
va devenir maintenant candidat citoyens
et bien il faut qu'ils débattent avec
les autres candidats battent résume là
c'est un peu le piège absolu serre
soient ils ils participent à un débat
d'avant le premier essai la cible de
tous les essais pas possible il n'y va
pas et il donne quand même le sentiment
de la confrontation
ça ne tiendra pas la route penser que
franchement il a peur qu'on y la montre
est quand même que la série sera quand
même pas d'accord moi je suis un peu
près persuadé que ça ne bougera pas je
pense que les français dans avec un peu
de bon sens se disent ouais c'est le
président de la république je vous
signale que depuis le début il dit qu'il
ira jusqu'au dernier quart d'heure 1
qu'il sera président jusqu'au bout donc
moi franchement je le vois pas prendre
un risque où il va être bombardé
effectivement par tous les autres
candidats puisqu'ils se ce sera l'homme
à abattre voilà il a du répondant donc
je suis pas sûr qu'il soit forcément
abattu mais ça ne sera pas un débat non
plus parce que pour qu'il y ait débat il
faut qu'ils aient un minimum de base à
partir de laquelle on puisse
effectivement argumenté si c'est là
vraiment sans possibilité longue des
journalistes la toul et oui ils se sont
positionnés ils ont tous proposé des
formes assez près 1 tout est finement
doute pas et donc et donc c'est le rôle
quand même des gens mal mais on serait
d'être là et de justement de mener est
d'ordre est sûr c'est pas toujours
évident de le faire même si c'est le rô
le rôle qu'ils doivent avoir vous avez
quand même un mélenchon qui n'est pas
toujours facile de cadres est vous avez
des situations tout simplement une
question de temps de parole
mécaniquement oui il aura douze fois
moins de temps de parole que le la
globalité
donc oui mais ça c'est normal oui oui
c'est la règle non mes scénarios il
manquerait que stratégiquement le chef
de l'état n'est pas intérêt à participer
à ce débat pour ne pas être criblé de
toutes les flèches de ses adversaires
évidemment mais politiquement je pense
que l'opinion n'accepterait plus
qu ils refusent de débattre avant le
premier tour je crois vraiment dommage
c'est vrai que c'est un terrain d'image
politiquement si ça renforcerait aussi
ça pour être même contre-productif pour
lui parce que ça pourrait renforcer
l'image de condescendance une image de
mépris une image de distance par rapport
par rapport à l'élection qui serait
quand même déjà
exemplaire président sortant elles ont
affronté mon premier tournant avant le
premier tour qui n'avaient pas de plan
sur vous aviez votre avis parce que
béatrice giblin avis totalement tranchée
est ce que c'est ce que cet arbitre est
totalement arbitré à l'elysée d'ailleurs
en tout cas d'après les bruits qui sort
tout il en est pas question mais ce qui
est étonnant justement dans ces danses
et brûla c'est que ça ne lui ressemble
pas tellement mails macron c'est plutôt
quelqu'un qui aime la bagarre et je n'ai
pas l'impression que ça lui déplairait
d'aller se bat seul à mains nues contre
15 personnes en essayant d'en tirer
profit donc si je pense que tu sois pas
totalement enterrée et du dos est lui
qui a le dernier mot et personne ne sait
autour de lui ce qu'il décidera in fine
est commun parce que c'est comme ça
qu'ils fonctionnent emmanuel macron donc
tous les conseillers qui arrosent les
journalistes d'information absolument
s'en méfier
surtout quand c'est le porte parole du
gouvernement qui le dit ça donne un côté
un peu officielle à la prise de position
qui permet de ménager un effet de revers
macron donc attendons mais là il
pourrait presque en tire est vrai dire
profite parce que l'annoncé qui veut pas
y aller et puis in fine et dire qu'il y
va alors c'est lui qui apparaît comme
l'homme courageux et tous les autres ce
que ça fait
on ne parle que moi un peu moins mais
que des manuels macron a parlé du jazz
aux oui mais voyez bien que le problème
c est la faiblesse de ses adversaires
ça tombe bien j'allais y venir merci
laetitia nous offrir la transition
fenech michaud pardon je vous ai appelé
françois donc bah si c'est pas bien donc
j'essaye j'essaye d'être précis aussi
sur le groupe mais a vite et donc mea
culpa mea maxima culpa je vais reprendre
un sondage de votre institut pour me
faire pardonner il ya deux semaines les
français qui portent un jugement très
critique sur cette campagne c'est quand
même intéressant on en a enfin je vais
peut-être vous laisser le détail mais
pas de bonne qualité n'aborde pas les
vrais problèmes enfin la liste elle est
impressionnante et très négatif oui mais
nous avions noté ce début de campagne un
peu un peu chaotique est effectivement
on a cherché à
mesurer la façon dont les français
perçoivent la façon dont le débat se
déroule effectivement le constat est
très sévère d'abord on a une large
majorité des français 58% qui nous dit
que le débat est trop agressif une
grande violence dans l'est dans les
échanges s'est partagé par tous les
électorats sauf l'électorat d'eric
zemmour
58% chez les français chez les électeurs
d'eric zemmour 38% comme si cet
électorat particulier t'es peut-être
moins sensibles à la dureté du
2d des polémiques et des et du débat et
puis sur le fond il n'aborde pas les
vrais problèmes pour trois quarts des
français il n'apporte pas de solution il
ne répond pas aux attentes des français
donc là vraiment d un constat massif est
vraiment
très partagés et puis au final on a
seulement moins d'un quart de la
population qui nous dit que le débat
électoral est de bonne qualité donc on
voit bien il ya une vraie frustration
par rapport à la façon dont le débat est
enclenchée sur l'agressivité comment
vous l'analysez peut-être françois
grellier vos mots parce que est ce que
comme on est un peu comme ça écrasé par
la crise qu vie de ce qu'il faut parler
encore plus fort ou être encore plus
agressive pour se faire entendre en tout
cas c'était la stratégie de certains
candidats tout toujours dans une
campagne le premier qui plante son
chapiteau installé le débat c'est donc
celui qui crie le plus fort dès le début
essayez d'articuler le débat autour de
lui pis ça c'est un enjeu aussi de poser
le thème de la campagne présidentielle
parce que vous organisez le débat autour
de vous et donc vous devenez le centre
des discussions c'est ce qu'on a vu à
partir de septembre avec eric zemmour
kaka qui a organisé tout le tout le tout
tous les débats de la rentrée autour
d'eux migration donc effectivement il ya
une prime à l'agressivité enfin
agressivité peut-être pas ce terme là
mais en tout cas au côté spectaculaire
et aux propos qui qui qui va
attirer l'oeil et l'oreille des français
qui justement l'eau à cause du coup ils
sont pas forcément pas forcément la tête
encore dans la campagne présidentielle
beaucoup oui il y à l'appui la
construction de l'élection
présidentielle ce mécanisme qui fait
comparé à 20 on arrive à 2 il n'en reste
qu'un provoque mécaniquement le des
affrontements donc c'est non là c'est
plutôt dans la logique des choses même
si parfois les
thèmes surface sur certains thèmes comme
l'immigration on voit qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de pâtes oui des dérapages
enfin que ça s'est un peu dérivé quand
même par rapport aux autres compagnes
qu'on a pu voir ouais et alors c'est
intéressant justement on va écouter eric
zemmour s'était hier devant le syndicat
de police alliance il continue de
creuser son sillon on écoute
j'ai proposé aussi
que la halle excuse de minorité soit
baissé de 16 à 13 ans et que les parents
de ces délinquants mineurs soient
privés de leurs allocations sociales et
exclu des hlm s'ils vivaient dans des
hlm et j'ai proposé aussi j'ai rappelé
que nous devions expulser tous je dis
bien tous les mineurs isolés
laiterie gibelin ont le sentiment que
j'ai c'est que
vous l'avez eric zemmour ne donne plus
tempo dans cette campagne une pipe de
longues semaines quand vous l'expliquer
mais parce que la préoccupation des
français n'est pas l'immigration au
premier chef la préoccupation des
français c'est le pouvoir d'achat
maintenant qui est vraiment pour une
question majeure ça peut être après les
problèmes de santé ou autres mais les
migrations viens je crois en troisième
ou quatrième position et je pense qu'il
sait la nra pour lui c'est absolument
viscéral bon donc il ne peut pas
attaquer sur autre chose véritablement
mais c'est même plutôt rassurant de voir
que l'ensemble des français ne met pas
cette question là et ne vit pas avec une
menace sur le grand remplacement sur la
disparition d'une identité française au
très sincèrement je crois grande partie
des français n'adhèrent pas à ce type de
discours on a pu penser que ce serait
effectivement le thème central avec la
sécurité alors la sécurité oui et peut
rester sans aide moi est très présent
bien sûr mais cette association qu'il
fait et ses prises de positions très
fermes ne peut s'adresser qu'un
électorat relativement réduits
relativement réduit ce mois je pense que
quand il dit on privera les familles
allocations familiales on renverra tout
le monde je pense qu'un certain nombre
de français qui écoute ça 10 ben non
c'est pas vrai ça ne sera pas possible
on le fera pas et donc ils n'adhèrent
pas donc son tempo qu'il a essayé de ce
thème qu'il a essayé d'imposer dont il
était persuadé que ce serait le thème
qu'ils puissent que je parte clash fille
sans tabou bon mais je pense qu'ils
aient un certain nombre de gens qui
quand ils l'entendent se rend très bien
compte que c'est pas crédible michaud
sait si on analyse les
tendances simple pas seulement voilà les
tout derniers sondages mais les
tendances autour d'eux des intentions de
vote pour l'eczéma
et sa perception par l'opinion on a on a
dit plusieurs fois ici qu'ils avaient un
niveau de détestation qui était très
élevé est ce que c'est tout simplement
passage le plafond de verre est
l'explication l'essoufflement de sa
campagne alors je ne parlerai pas
d'essoufflement on a une campagne qui
reste relativement stable dans les têtes
dans les intentions de vote pendant tout
le mois de janvier alors certes il ne
progresse pas mais il n'est pas relégué
au second plan un commando comme on
aurait pu s'y attendre il débuta qui
n'est pas passée sous les 10%
il se maintient entre 13 et 14% les
effets des ralliements successifs
hebdomadaire puisque c'est tous les
week-ends que sa campagne a choisi
d'annoncer des ralliements on voit bien
que c'est une stratégie ont eu jusqu'à
présent pas d'effet pour guillaume
pelletier par exemple des effets très
limités
éphémère pour gilbert collard et puis
nous suivons les effets d'un éventuel
ralliement de marion maréchal-le pen
bref est pour l'instant lié par les gays
mais n'arrive pas non plus à progresser
effectivement la thématique de campagne
centrale pour l'instant en attente des
français c'est la question du pouvoir
d'achat et lui son électorat
est beaucoup plus attentifs à la
question de l'immigration donc il fait
la politique de son électorat mais il ne
parvient pas pour l'instant à élargir à
l'ensemble des français et à s'adresser
à l'ensemble de la population et donc à
parler de pouvoir d'achat et de
protection sociale parce que c'est le
deuxième enjeu un la santé les retraites
etc il ya eu quelques meetings vrai
qu'on termine là dessus qu'on était
quand même marquant un meeting d'eric
zemmour celui de de jean luc mélenchon
françois xavier bron mais est ce que
finalement quand même et il revient à la
question du la crise sanitaire on n'est
pas un peu en manque de grands meetings
dans cette campagne près ici puisque
c'est un meeting c'est essentiel dans
une campagne présidentielle ça permet de
montrer de la force les seuls qui ont
montré de la force jusqu'à présent mais
c'est eric zemmour à villepinte et jean
luc mélenchon avec son premier meeting
spectaculaire voilà mr sa main immersif
qui isole il ya eu il ya eu un effet ben
on avance on a vu qu'ils avaient des
troupes qu'il ait tiré c'était capable
de rassembler du monde
autour d'eux des personnes pour les
écouter d'ailleurs les meetings vont
reprendre puisque ce week end il ya eric
zemmour encore et marine le pen la
semaine prochaine il ya valérie pécresse
qui fait son grand meeting de lancement
et puis bon après on verra emmanuel
macron continuer quand il entrera en
campagne mais le meeting c'est un moment
essentiel
des meetings à l'extérieur des wisigoths
qu'il essaye de varier
original donc cesser ses meetings ou ici
en plus à cause des conditions
sanitaires et des restrictions ça
devient compliqué de l'est de les
organiser bon ça enlève de l'intérêt à
la campagne j'ai vu récemment que chez
eric zemmour le olivier ubeda qui
s'occupe de ça de l'organisation de ces
événements réfléchir à un meeting à 30
mille cinquante mille personnes donc
résiliées il est possible que cette
campagne soit courte mais intense et
spectaculaire sur le sur la fin est ce
que finalement il revient à ce dont
parlait laetitia tout à l'heure béatrice
giblin les annales cette offre
médiatique
pléthorique est-ce qu'elle n'a pas ou
aussi remplacer un peu les meetings en
tout cas dans cette première phase de
campagne moi je suis pas dans la
première phase absolument sûrement
surtout qu'avec la pandémie on peut pas
vraiment à écran campagne sur et sur
écran moi je m'interroge un peu sur la
l'impact si vous voulez des campagnes
par réseaux sociaux que ce soit vous les
avez cité à rester gras et tout ce qu'on
veut tu sais je suis pas sûr s'il ya
beaucoup de gens 1 parce que c'est
facile on regarde c'est quelques minutes
on passe à autre chose
est-ce que c'est essentiellement des
jeunes quand même beaucoup plus parce
qu'il fonctionne comme ça
est-ce que ça va les mobiliser pour
aller jusqu'au vote ça c'est une
interrogation et ou bien malin à mon
avis celui qui est capable de le de le
dire en revanche qu est-ce qui va voter
les personnes âgées ce que vous avez
rappelé c'est à dire la maturité
l'engagement et c est ça les personnes
âgées vont aller voter elles y sont
c'est dans les 50% qui savent déjà pour
qui elles vont voter et elles sont sûrs
d'y aller j'ai tendance à dire c'est
quand même plutôt les vieux qui font
l'élection présidentielle que les jeunes
c'est pas rassurant un je ne
sais un constat que je fais mais je suis
absolument pas sûr que ce phenom si vous
voulez au canton 10 7 millions de vues
parce que marine le pen elle a mis son
chat sous le sapin felli c'est assez
consternant s'il
devait mourir en a 7 millions ha oui
parce qu'il a lancé une boule de bowling
et puis il a dû marquer beaucoup de
points finans mais c'est honnêtement
c'est parce c'est pas sérieux c'est pas
avec ça qu'on imprime sur tel ou je
l'espère qu'on imprime pour ce qui est
une présidentielle si vous voulez donc
c'est peut-être un début d'engagement
qu'il faudra du temps pour qu'ils
passent tous ces gens jeunes à autre
chose mais il faut rappeler quand même
qu'en 2017 on avait déjà une forte
abstention des jeunes alors je ne parle
pas de l'abstention aux régionales où je
crois que c'était 87 % des jeunes de 18
à 24 ans qui n'étaient pas allés voter
donc il ya de la marge pour les faire
revenir aux présidentielles et d'une
certaine façon est ce que
opinionway hemera la même chose les
jeunes pour le moment c'est eux qui sont
pour macron dans le pourcentage le plus
élevé vite oui merci ça s'appelle
s'adapter à la demande de l'animateur
merci beaucoup et on l'appelle le titre
de votre livre le sacre de l'opinion
c'est aux éditions du cerf
françois-xavier bourmaud macron le pen
le tango des fossoyeurs aux éditions de
l'archipel toutes mes excuses en
coulisses on va rigoler rur de prénom